الجيش السوداني والدعم السريع يتبادلان
مواقع السيطره نقابه الاطباء تعلن وقتها
لا نحو 100 شخص لبنان يقفل في باريس
ويدمجها مع السفاره هذه الاخبار وغيرها
نقلها لكم من قناه العربيه فاهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
نبدا من السودان حيث تستمر المعارك هناك
بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
لليوم الثالث على التوالي وتتركز في
العاصمه الخرطوم ومحيط قاعده مراوي اضافه
الى مناطق اخرى وفيما قال الجيش ان جميع
مقرات القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه ما
زالت تحت السيطره رغم الاشتباكات التي
تدور منذ ساعات طويله تصر قوات الدعم
السريع على انها هي من تسيطر على تلك
المقرات كما تؤكد سيطرتها على القاعده
الجويه في مطار مروي العسكري
وعلى وقع المعارك المستمره اعلنت نقابه
اطباء السودان ارتفاع حصيله ضحايا
الاشتباكات بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
الى نحو 100 قتيل حتى الان محذره من ان
الحصيله قد تكون اكبر نظرا لصعوبه الوصول
الى الكثير من الجرحى بسبب شده الاشتباكات
النقابه ادانت عبر بيان لها صراع السلطه
الحاليه بين البرهان وحميدتي معلنه ان عدد
من المستشفيات في الخرطوم خرجت عن الخدمه
واضافت ان قصف المرافق الصحيه يعد انتهاكا
واضحا للقانون الدولي الاسلامي والمواثيق
التي تنص على حمايه المؤسسه الصحيه
في خبر اثار جدلا في لبنان نقلت وسائل
الاعلام محليه عن الخارجيه اللبنانيه
تعتزم نقل او اغلاق قنصلياتها في باريس
ابتداء من يوم غد الثلاثاء ودمج خدماتها
مع خدمات السفاره اللبنانيه هناك وسائل
الاعلام لبنانيه قالت ان اغلاق القنصليه
ياتي في اطار توفير النفقات حيث تبلغ كلفه
ايجار هذه القنصليه السنويه نحو 220 الف
يورو وتقع في جاده ملاقوف في الدائره
السادسه عشر من باريس فيما ياتي الاجراء
بحسب المصادر ضمن حمله التقشف في وزاره
الخارجيه لجهه الاستغناء عن ايجارات
المباني المكلفه وخفض عدد الموظفين
الى هذا الخبر السار الذي زفته شركه
مدارنه ومارك لمرضى سرطان الجلد حيث اعلنت
عن تطوير لقاح جديد لمنع المصابين من
الانتكاس وكشف باحثون ان نحو 79% من مرضى
سرطان الجلد الذين حصلوا على اللقاح الى
جانب علاج كيترودا المناعي شوفوا تماما من
السرطان في غضون 18 شهرا كما قالت
الشركتان المطورتان للقاح انها ستوسعان
الابحاث لتشمل انواع اخرى من الاورام بما
في ذلك سرطان الرئه ذو الخلايا غير
الصغيره
خبرنا الاخير من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه التي اعلنت نفوق اكثر من 58
مليون طائر معظمها من الدجاج جراء تفشي
خطير لانفلونزا الطيور في البلاد منذ
بدايه العام الفار حتى الان وفقا لمركزي
مكافحه الامراض والوقايه منها المركز اضاف
انه يختبر عددا من اللقاحات المحتمله
الانفلونزا الطيور لتحسين الدواجن والبط
والاوز والحمام وغيرها لكن هذا الامر قد
يستغرق ما يتراوح بين 18 الى 24 شهرا على
الاقل حتى يجهز اللقاح